it's a disgrace that next week four army
veterans
could be charged with murder over the
deaths of bloody sunday protesters
almost five decades ago soldiering on
the front line is an incredibly
difficult task making life-changing
decisions whilst faced by the enemy
isn't for the faint-hearted to follow
orders
you were given then have your actions
picked apart
by someone who spent his life polishing
a leather chair
is an insult a man who's never had to
make a split-second call whilst under
fire
is not qualified to pass judgment on a
man who has
that's a fact defense secretary gavin
williamson
is reportedly pushing for a 10-year
limit on the prosecution for soldiers
for alleged historical abuses this would
be a start
but i'd also like to see politicians who
sanctioners take some culpability
as well as assurances that soldiers will
be left alone if they haven't strayed
from the orders they were given finally
i believe that any investigation should
be chaired by someone
who has been there seen it and done it
not just a suit trying to appease the pc
brigade
[Music]
phil i'm i don't think this is an easy
issue is it it's not as simple as i
think as you're saying
when i was chairman of the fa i was
chairman of the hillsborough committee
there as well and i got to know the
hillsborough families quite well
and what they wanted uh
was a prosecution and which is what
they've got and that's why we can't talk
anymore about it
and i suspect uh the bloody sunday
families are looking for the same thing
they're saying
the last inquiry there were two
inquiries one
found against them one the second much
longer inquiry found
uh by and large for them and i suspect
they are looking for some prosecutions
now
i don't want soldiers to be ex-soldiers
in their 70s to go to jail because i
wouldn't put anybody who's not a threat
to society in jail anyway i don't think
there's any point
but i suspect they will be disappointed
if there aren't some prosecutions
well firstly these soldiers were acting
under orders okay yeah
secondly this is a wider problem as well
and if we go and have a look at all my
mate briarwood
briar was one of the first soldiers to
fix bayonet since the world wars
you know involved in an incredible
action probably if you ask me
you know he is an absolute model soldier
okay and he was dragged through the
coals by shiner in the game so let's
just have a look at what
what brian's got to say and then we'll
open it a bit further he was involved in
a famous battle known as the battle of
danny boy we've seen soldiers
close and destroy a multiple enemy
position and then years later
get accused of murder mutilation and
mistreatment
what would your message be to the powers
that be now to rectify this problem of
soldiers being sort of hauled across the
coals
look we've got to adhere to rules of
engagement and
the human law it's absolutely and we do
but
there's also got to be a statutory
limitation there's got to be a timeline
a cut off you can't just
start hounding soldiers decades and
decades after
the event i mean if there's something
there needs to be investigated there and
then and nipped in the bud because i
went through it myself
and after you know 10 years of pure pain
and to be found holy with that
foundation a degree of product of
deliberate lies
danny boy was in iraq and and a really
really hard fought battle
where i'm coming with this this you
can't just keep these things open for
years and years and years and you need a
credible person to turn around and say
yes this happened that didn't happen
that happened and evidence it and
and look at it with a with a perspective
from somebody who understands
what is going on in the arena and not
just you know just to reference china
again that's of course
phil scheiner who took so many cases
against that's the one yeah that's the
one i mean
it's just a quick one from me just a
quick one from me and you'll know far
better than i
used to describe as a disgrace i think
it's a farce because if a soldier is put
into court and he said well why did you
well colonel colonel jones gave me the
order colonel jones is now in the great
parade ground on this one or it was
captain smith
none of these people who gave those many
of them will have died of natural causes
or whatever
so you'll never be able to have a proper
trial how can you do that
i i think you know a lot of people in
this country will watch the witch hunt
that has gone on against our soldiers
and
and i think it would sicken them to
their stomachs you know we
we ask men and women to put their lives
on the line to defend this country to do
stuff that we couldn't or don't want to
do
we can't ask them to do that if there
are no protections in place for them so
if gavin
williamson is going to bring forward um
this this 10-year
limit in in the queen's speech that's
that's fine but he also has to
bring through rules about the kind of
evidence
that you would you would prosecute
someone almost you can't just cover 25
years later and say he because
there's got to be there's got to be
rules about the kind of evidence you're
using yes
of course i agree if soldiers if there
is evidence of criminal behavior
um yes this should be prosecuted but i
think let me just say one thing
the iraq the historic of iraq historical
allegations team
investigation team 1500 cases and
northmoor which was investigating cases
in afghanistan
500 cases do we really think there were
two and a bit thousand soldiers abusing
like your mate said
murdering mutilating and mistreating
people i i don't believe it
that's the reason we have a process and
we have rule of law carol and
you know there are already there are
already safeguards around decisions to
prosecute you already have to show that
there is evidence and that's in the
public interest
to prosecute someone so just soldiers
cases don't
point it out a lot of the people who had
evidence in bloody sunday are now dead
and can people really remember stuff
twenty can we talk about the victims as
well the victims of bloody sunday and
other events like that didn't want to
have to wait until now to see justice
either it's not nobody wanted it to take
this long and the idea that
victims shouldn't get to see justice
because it's taken so long so many
inquiries
what about what about the victims of
birmingham we actively no one's gone
after them after in fact they actually
handed them all that letters to say
you're safe now that's you're okay
that's the disgrace with more injustice
let me theresa may agrees with you so
let me just show you what she
says about this we have uh an unfair
situation at the moment the situation we
have at the moment is that the only
people being investigated
for things that happened in the part of
these issues that happened in the past
are those in our armed forces or those
who served in law enforcement
in northern ireland that is patently
unfair
terrorists are not being investigated
terrorists
should be investigated and that is what
the government wants to see
in the interest of balance i just want
to read you what shin fein says which is
radically different these remarks are
deeply insensitive to the loss and pain
of hundreds of families
who have been bereaved by the british
state forces they have caused deep hurt
and offense
and could even undermine confidence in
the rule of law in the administration of
justice
they are also demonstrably untrue as has
been evidenced by official statistics
and statements on legacy
investigations you know i think phil
there are two issues you're talking
about the person who's involved in this
overseeing inquiries or prosecutions
should understand the reality of the
battlefield
i agree with that but the idea that we
shouldn't hold people to account and it
that it's in the interest of our armed
forces to know
that we have a military that is
respected around the world because it
enforces high standards
of the rules of engagement and
respecting human rights and you do that
by accountability
this is a private soldier that on the
day of the race it was all going noisy
he was acting under the orders he was
doing an extremely dangerous job he was
probably looking after himself his buddy
and trying to do a decent job okay in an
absolute
melee and then seventy years later he's
getting pulled through the council
that's insane no surgery who's following
a lawful order
should ever be prosecuted it's not their
job to sit there and work out whether
that lauder is
whether that order is lawful or right
it's their job to do whatever that's
what
that's what the court would decide but
it's not disgusting
you're saying you we we should have a
ten year amount of time basically don't
go back more than ten years
does that apply to all court cases do
you apply that to the whole i don't even
regret it
actually to be honest i i i just i just
think it's really unfair on so
it is soldiers need to know that they
have the government and they have the
military on this
and that is such a so if a soldier
doesn't think that he's going to get the
backing of the government for carrying
out the actions that he's been told to
how can he carry those actions out with
confidence actually undermine the army
by not backing him up
undermine those soldiers cases they've
taken years to investigate and you're
portraying them
as really black and white because
brian's was that brian's case was done
overnight the reason why
they got to the stage of being the
subject of a prosecution
now is because there is enough grounds
to believe
that they weren't just following lawful
orders and acting in the case
but there have been there were 303
668 claims have been made against
british troops
uh allegations right there have been no
prosecutions
there have been no prosecutions in iraq
so because i presume
because we have a system of laws would
you stop people making allegations then
as well carol
well no no but i just think when you
have lawyers whose
whole raison d'etre is to make a profit
and when you have those lawyers getting
people in places like iraq and
afghanistan
going to look for people who may or may
not what would you say
but from china's law do you accept that
it's possible that there have been
abuses by the british enforcers there
are genuine victims that exist and if
you accept that that's possible
what do you recommend for those people
to get the army has its own rank system
in place as well to safeguard against
that it also is controlled from the very
top so
what i'm saying is the only person
getting hauled through the coals is
private bacon neck who's there and
they're on the sharp end of the day
it's not colonel bogey at the top all
right and it's not the politician that
sent him and it's interesting
politicians as soon as you say
politicians because it's worth noting of
course that northern ireland secretary
karen bradley was in trouble over that
earlier in the week she said that she
thought
the death cause were quotes not crimes
we need to now say she has
apologized i'm profoundly sorry for the
offense and hurt that my words have
caused language was wrong
even though it was not my intention it
was deeply insensitive to many of those
who lost
loved ones and they wonder why the army
has a recruiting crisis